hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to talk to you
about buy to let mortgages maybe you're
thinking about buying a house and you're
wondering what type of a mortgage you
should get on that house if it's an
investment property it very likely will
be a buy to let mortgage i'm going to be
talking about interest rates whether you
should fix them repayment versus
interest only so if you are going to buy
a house as an investment i would highly
suggest watching this video until the
end before you consider taking out a
mortgage and certainly buying a house as
a buy to let so if you enjoy my videos a
lot of research goes into this and i
spend so much time preparing these and
going into all the different rates and
information and research so please give
me a massive favor and hit the like
button so firstly what is a buy to let
mortgage well firstly what's a mortgage
a mortgage is a loan
against a house so if you're buying a
house even if you're buying it to live
in let's say you want to buy a house and
it's
300 000 pound house most people don't
have 300 000 cash so what they do is
they put down a deposit of 10 20 30 and
then the rest they'll take out as a loan
a mortgage against the house now if
you're buying a house to live in
the mortgage will be a residential
mortgage and if you're getting a
residential mortgage the lender the
mortgage company will want to know that
you can afford to pay the mortgage so
they're going to want to know your
salary your earnings how many children
you have
what because they need to know hang on a
minute if you've got all these kids
maybe they're expensive to have and they
need to know that you can afford to pay
about the mortgage so getting a
residential mortgage usually you have to
give a lot of forms a lot of form
filling out to give you financial
criteria a buy tech mortgage very
different
that's when you're getting a mortgage to
buy a house but it's not going to be a
residential house that you're living in
it's going to be a house that you're
buying to rent out hence why it's called
a buy to let mortgage now typically buy
select mortgage you're going to need a
deposit of 25
so if you're buying a house for 200 000
pounds they're going to expect you to
have 50 000 pounds as a deposit and then
the mortgage companies will loan you 75
as a 75 loan to value buy to let
mortgage
so do you need any experience of owning
properties do you need to be making a
particular amount of income in order to
qualify for a buy to let mortgage and
the answer is no not really you can get
a buy to let mortgage even if you don't
have a residential mortgage although it
does help if you own a house um to begin
with but i did not oh my first house was
a buy to let you also don't need to be
earning a great deal either in fact the
interesting thing about a buy direct
mortgage is the lender cares
not about your income because you're not
going to be paying the mortgage
the buy to let mortgage is going to
effectively being paid by the tenants
that live in your buy to the house so
the thing that they'll want to know is
how much rent are the tenants going to
be paying that's the big thing that
lenders will want to know even if you're
only making five ten thousand pound a
year and your salary is really really
low you will still very likely be able
to qualify for a buy to let mortgage as
long as the property is a decent house
and they can see that the rent is going
to be able to cover the paint the the
interest payments so what are the
interest payments on buy to let
mortgages
generally speaking
they historically if you've been
watching my videos i'll be saying maybe
three percent or they're in their abouts
now they have recently put interest
rates up a little bit so then now the
average buy to let mortgage is around
about four percent interest i have
recently just
refinanced a whole bunch of my houses
and i used a lender called the mortgage
lender that was the name of the mortgage
lender and i've fixed my interest rates
for five years because i can see the
interest rates are going up
usually i'll fix them for two years but
at these times because interest rates do
seem to be rising i fixed them for five
years and i i've got a 25-year term
mortgage and i fixed them at
3.3 percent so i'm very pleased with
that and that's fixed for five years so
that means i'm gonna be paying 260
pounds a month which is going to be my
interest payments but my rent on the
house this one is 750. so my profit is
there they're about 500 pounds a month
so even if interest rates went up in
five years time if they go up even if my
rents don't go up if the rent stays the
same but the interest rate after five
year goes up unless it goes up to ten
percent i'm still going to be making
money
i'm quite comfortable with that i'm
quite happy with that should you pay
interest only or should you pay
repayment
my general guidance what i usually do is
i pay interest only which means that i'm
not actually paying back the loan i'm
just maintaining the interest on the on
the loan and the reason i do that is
because the extra cash flow that i'm
making if i'm making 500 a month profit
from one house i'm going to save that
money i'm going to get it into a little
pot and then i'm going to buy another
house
and that house is going to pay me 500
pounds a month and i'm going to save
that and i'm going to snowball my
portfolio and i'm going to use the
bank's money
because if i'm paying down the mortgage
i'm not making any monthly cash flow so
my general strategy
is to pay as little back as possible
because your debt will shrink over time
as the value of the house goes up which
it probably will as the rent goes up
which it probably will but the debt
stays the same money shrinks in value
over time money becomes worth less over
time as they print more and more money
as inflation goes up so i'm not wanting
to rush to pay off my mortgage my
granddad bought a house many years ago
for three thousand pounds he put down a
one thousand pound deposit he had a two
thousand pound mortgage he spent ten
years slaving away paying off that two
thousand pound mortgage my goodness he'd
be better to just leave that mortgage
and then after 10 20 30 40 50 years the
2000 pounds is nothing because inflation
goes up and money becomes worth less so
my attitude is debt shrinks over time so
don't rush to pay it off um our interest
rate rate's going to go up yes i think
they will i don't think they're going to
go absolutely scary anything crazy but i
do think we're going to see significant
rises so i would probably suggest that
you fix them for as long as possible and
last question is should you use a
mortgage broker my general guidance is
yes because there's so many mortgages
out there just because i use the
mortgage lender doesn't mean that
they'll be best for you because every
person is an individual with different
finances different ability to pay
different things maybe there are some
lenders that might be stricter on you or
you or you so what you want is you want
to go to a mortgage broker or a mortgage
advisor and you want to tell them your
situation tell them what you're wanting
to do get actual advice and let them
independently look at the whole of the
market and give you the best mortgage
offer with the best rates specifically
for you yes you're gonna pay them a few
hundred pounds for doing it but you'll
save a lot more in the long run in my
opinion i hope that's been helpful as i
mentioned smash the like button if you
found it helpful drop a comment and i'll
see you next time
[Music]